[Música]
pues muy muy buenas tardes muchas
gracias
american school foundation y ate tax por
estar esta invitación
hoy hubiera querido venirme aquí a esta
plática en transporte público me ha
encantado llegar aquí caminando me ha
encantado llegar en bicicleta sin
embargo la infraestructura de la ciudad
no da para que esto sea posible
entonces me vine como todos en carro
monterrey es una ciudad que tiene más
carros que espacios para transporte
público y eso es de lo que vamos a
platicar el día de hoy esta es una
escena muy común que vemos todos los que
vivimos en esta ciudad esto es algo del
día a día pareciera que ya es algo
normal pareciera que es algo a lo que
tenemos que estar sometidos para poder
llegar a nuestra casa y con una
situación que nos resta algo muy
importante que es la razón para la que
venimos al mundo
esto nos resta felicidad
calidad de vida y sin embargo nos
estamos acostumbrando a lidiar con esto
día con día y lo peor es que la manera
en la que lo queremos resolver es con
más avenidas
es decir en la ciudad de mexico por
ejemplo cuando el periférico se saturó
dijeron ya sé cuál es la solución vamos
a hacer un segundo piso en el periférico
para que dentro de 10 años empezarán a
decir ya se volvió a saturar ahora el
segundo piso se me hace que la solución
es hacer un tercer piso imagínense si
ciudades primermundistas de vanguardia
hubiesen pensado de esa manera
este sería parís el día de hoy lo que
ustedes ven es el campo marte y no
solamente parís entendió que hacer más
avenidas no reduce el tráfico
también lo entendieron a ámsterdam
medellín toronto y bien a las cuatro
ciudades con una alta calidad de vida
ciudades donde la gente donde el índice
de felicidad es elevado y ciudades donde
la movilidad es una garantía para los
ciudadanos que viven en ellas
pero bueno regresemos a nuestra realidad
monterrey es una ciudad que tiene 2.2
millones de carros para 4 millones de
personas que vivimos aquí
es decir en monterrey hay 1.9 habitantes
por cada carro pensamos que la ciudad de
mexico es la ciudad con más tráfico del
país y pensamos en ejemplos caóticos
como nueva delhi o como bangkok
y nos estamos convirtiendo en esto véalo
aquí actualmente el número de carros por
habitante que tiene monterrey es similar
al de la ciudad de mexico y al de nueva
delhi con la pequeña diferencia que
ellos tienen dos de líneas de metro
nueve líneas de metro y nosotros 2.5
y ahora vamos a ver qué espacios de
transporte público tenemos en monterrey
para resolver este problema
miren si si contamos el número de
vagones de metro el número de asientos
que tiene cada vagón de metro y el
número de espacios para que vayas en el
metro parado en total caben 16 mil 800
personas la ecovía que es un proyecto
bien intencionado pero fallido a final
de cuentas le caben mil 168 personas y
luego si vemos si multiplicamos el
número de taxis por el número de
personas que caben en cada taxi nos da
un total de 112 mil personas y el número
de uber que tenemos en la ciudad y
califa y otras aplicaciones por el
número de personas que caben en cada
unidad nos da un total de 104 mil en el
transporte urbano caben 200 mil personas
y el transporte escolar 55 mil dando un
total de 488 mil 968 espacios espacios
de transporte público
una ciudad que tiene cuatro veces más
caros 2.2 millones de carros tiene
monterrey esto no lleva han hecho otras
ciudades pero en el caso de berlín
berlín es una ciudad que tiene menos
habitantes que monterrey sin embargo
berlín es una ciudad que tiene 11 líneas
de metro y monterrey es una ciudad que
tiene dos líneas y media de metro para
una mayor cantidad de habitantes las
consecuencias cuáles son la primera es
que disminuye nuestra calidad de vida a
mí me enseñaron en la universidad que la
persona es el principio centro y fin de
la existencia apareciera que aquí el
vehículo es el principio centro y fin de
la existencia la razón de ser de esta
ciudad la segunda es que afecta el
crecimiento económico y también genera
contaminación y eso daría tema para otra
te toca pero sin embargo si quiero
tratar el tema hoy monterrey también es
ya la ciudad más contaminada de mexico
ya se acabó el mito de que cuando vas a
la ciudad de mexico te tienes que cuidar
del smog y de la polución y de las
partículas pm 2.5 y pm 10
la ciudad más contaminada de este país
ya le ganamos a méxico y ya le ganamos a
toluca y esto causa ya 5.000 muertes al
año y hay personas que dicen no es que
eso es por las montañas es por las
pedreras es por otras razones
no amigos una de las principales causas
de la contaminación que tenemos en
monterrey es el uso excesivo del
vehículo de donde viene la contaminación
el 45 por ciento de esa contaminación
viene de los carros tenemos que dejar de
usar el carro
qué soluciones se pueden plantear para
este problema lo primero es una
planeación urbana adecuada cosa que no
se ha hecho en nuestra ciudad un niño
armando una ciudad del ego puede armar
algo mejor que lo que hemos armado entre
todos en monterrey más transporte
público y mejor transporte público
incentivos a las empresas las empresas
quieren ayudar para las empresas también
necesitan recompensas para tener buenas
prácticas verificación vehícular el
ciudadano que usemos menos el carro que
incrementamos la demanda para que mejore
la oferta si más personas nos subimos al
transporte público los que se encargan
de la administración de ese transporte
tendrán que mejorar el servicio así como
las personas que van al estadio del tec
eventualmente pidieron un mejor estadio
y tienen un mejor estadio en guadalupe y
así como eventualmente las personas que
van al universitario tendrán un mejor
estadio porque porque la demanda es alta
necesitamos incrementar la demanda para
que también mejore la oferta de nuestro
transporte público la iniciativa privada
promueve el carpool que son iniciativas
que ya han hecho otras ciudades con
muchísimo éxito y la inversión también
en transporte público
monterrey queremos en 20 años
recuerden el monterrey de hace 10 o de
hace 20 años
vean el monterrey de hoy y pensemos cuál
es la ciudad que queremos dentro de 20
años y después preguntémonos si estamos
haciendo lo correcto para lograr eso
yo les pregunto si queremos una ciudad
caótica una ciudad de carros una ciudad
contaminada con segundos terceros y
cuartos pisos una ciudad donde muchos
las banquetas para hacer más avenidas o
queremos una ciudad sustentable con una
alta calidad de vida donde todos
tengamos derecho a lo que venimos al
mundo a ser felices y por último yo
quisiera cerrar esta intervención
diciéndoles que si bien es cierto es
necesario que nos bajemos del automóvil
también es cierto que hacen falta
razones de peso para que lo hagamos las
banquetas los parques el transporte
público y lo más importante una cultura
de entender que venimos al mundo a
compartir espacio y que en este mundo
vivimos todos y también que tenemos una
herencia histórica con las futuras
generaciones qué tipo de ciudad le vamos
a dejar a la gente que venga después de
nosotros cierro con esta frase hacer más
vías
es la vida muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]